[Music]
welcome to socast number
24 and I want to thank as always Joo
willing productions for making this
possible in conjunction with s
Chronicles today we're rejoined uh by
Pat Watkins and we're going to start
with August 23rd
1968 which was a day of a tragic day for
Special Forces history where 16 Green
Berets were killed in one night battle
at fob4 in daang at the time and I'm
going to read a couple of uh sections
from on the ground about that night and
um then we'll go right to Pat Watkins
with his personal involvement that night
and it was a night with was no
moon and it was after midnight after
some people had done some
drinking and the the NBA sappers had
planned this attack for over a year and
they came through the wire they were in
the base and then they launched the
attack and that night Pat was up in the
in the residential barracks in in the
visit travel Transit
Barracks so you're up there with pigpen
and AKA Joe Colin and Parks was there
too spider until he left to go back down
house 22 took my sweede K and left
left me with a 45 so that night you had
gone back to the transit barracks and
then reading from the book when the
first aerial flares ignited over fob4
compound Pat Watkins and Sergeant Joe
Colin hit the floor of the transia
barracks amid the rattle of gunfire an
inexperienced first lieutenant stood
looking out a window the Lieutenant's
silhouette made a perfect Target a high
explosion interrupted just outside the
Barracks knocking the lieutenant on his
ass he sat there in shock clutching his
right arm where a piece of shrapnel had
GED a nasty wound as conin moved to
dress the Lieutenant's wounds another
massive explosion rocked the building so
hard that the light fixtures fell from
the
ceiling figuring that the transit
Barracks were next in line to receive a
satchel charge through a window or
doorway Watkins shouted that they should
move out into a larger area of the
hallway where they might have a chance
to defend off and attack con low crawled
to the left to cover the East End of the
hallway Watkin sneaked his right to his
right cursing himself because he let
spider Parks borrow his a his Swedish K
9mm submachine
gun
Watkins continued crawling through the
end of the hallway he froze silhouetted
by the flare light in the doorway an NVA
Soldier cautiously peered in to
determine if anyone inside was still
alive he was also trying to ignite a
satchel charge but was having some
difficulty the sapper gave up on the
Satchel charge and Watkins saw a hand
grenade rolling down the hall towards
him Watkins quickly fired two rounds at
the sapper and shouted
grenade instinctively he covered his
head with his hands and the force of the
explosion pushed Watkins back down the
hall peppering his hands arms and back
with shrapnel he figured this was it he
was as good as
dead that historic night my God Pat yeah
that's uh and again by again we're
welcoming Pat Watkins to uh our podcast
returning thank you for coming back well
you got the car keys so I had
to it's always the
key yeah that's a as you said it's a to
this day it's the most lost of
casualties in one battle Special Forces
for special and another thing too is uh
there were 66 purple hearts given out
that night that night for that action
for that action and not counting the uh
support the Sue
right our indigenous troops yeah Special
Commando units that we had they got
killed too and they killed our they
killed the uh Vietnamese cooks that were
in getting breakfast ready for the for
the people they slit their throats to
those were the two men that went down to
the indigenous messall and on being know
to
them before the attack was launched the
NVA sappers had infiltrated into the
base fob4 and dang and they went and
using the indigenous troops meshall for
a final briefing before they launched
the attack yeah it was definitely an
inside job clearly yeah it's it was kind
of ironic because I I was a foai with
you of course as a cover writer and so
spider Parks uh who was EUR one zero at
one time and uh I just put a team on the
ground in the ashow and come back from
and landed at at and turned it over to
Hillsboro cuz getting getting mad and
spider was waiting for me in the Jeep
which we did you know to get a ride back
to F to the compound and he had he
says I got your uniform and stuff here
and I said what he had clean uniform he
says we got to go to an a to a promotion
board and now it takes some real brains
to to
establish you know promotion board this
got to be you know senior officers on a
vanity kick for us goddamn soldiers
fighting for our lives to go stand there
and ask if we know our general orders or
some kind of crap I was you know I had
at that time I had over 10 years in the
service you know right sure but anyhow
make a long story short
got it we jumped on a king be with John
Peters was on it and and Doug godshaw
Doug was on it John Walton on it with
you John was John was on the same
helicopter with us and I didn't ask him
about Walmart stock at that time but
there was no Walmart his dad just had
five quote five and St right I heard
that story too yeah so anyhow we we
headed to uh den and had guys from
milock or LA s my that was still called
fob3 after they closed Kon yeah it was
really the L was part of fob1 right U
major Sincere was worked for bar bar was
his boss right Colonel Bor so anyhow we
get there and I I I told you that story
you know we got probed on on uh in
December 67 yeah right when you first
open when you first open F will be
Christmas Day Christmas Day Christmas
night and they
uh and retrospect which you know war is
always easier to judge in retrospect
they were practicing to see how our
alert system worked and everything which
was you know we couldn't put Minds out
because it wouldn't let it put Minds out
you know the wire was just nothing more
than two strands of Bob wire Bob wire
and some constantina thrown in on it and
they we had no God we had that quick
relaxtion Force to you know R rent a
cops to we had guys that couldn't run
Recon and stuff being L people they were
supposed to be the security for the com
and that night we got hit uh all of us
guys are just knew we just got our teams
and we practice you know and I'd went
out there with uh Kim bu who was an old
SF guy have been around and that's first
respected yeah and boot boot ended up
running the LA side of Quant tree yeah
on my third tour there he uh we both
said well where's the secondary fighting
positions you know there's your primary
have secondary to you fall back if you
have to yeah you have to and you know at
least we had to have trip you know trip
flares out here sure and all this [__]
and you know I me you know I brought
that up to Sergeant Major Harris who was
haris har Harris yeah Harr
and he said well don't say anything they
have you out here doing
it and I went yeah that's true they we
had no support it was really shitty but
they hit us that it was a probing
elevant they hit us and uh they started
they started shoot they shot some
mortars off of uh Marvel Mountain Mar
mountain and just for set the scene fob4
was on the south end of dang it was east
of Highway 1 and it was at the base of
marble Mountain which were several
mountains that just jutted out from
nowhere they were religious sites and
there were religious sites they had they
had uh Buddhist temples up there right
and we couldn't car they said couldn't
carry guns up there you know they had
these goddamn communist um U you know
monks czers yeah monks monks up there
you know and so leading up to August
23rd
1968 um they had Consolidated the
command we had the command control
element that was at the air base they
brought all those people in and put them
at F4 yeah then they had the promotion
board and had people down and then
earlier that day all the six fobs had
all their command elements that came in
for a monthly meeting so there's extra
people there and they the NBA and the
Via Kong local sappers along with their
infiltrators had planned this attack for
over a year and they they launched it
when it was dark so your early
experience with
December you felt that on that night of
the 23rd you knew this was a probe just
a test I I spent three and a half months
of qu on I knew what incoming fire sound
like you know it was not this was not a
prodal deal to me I as soon as I you
know I heard it and I said well hell
we're being
mortared and you know being a good
combat troop I was I put the mattress
over my head and got on the floor yeah a
little thin and Joe Joe conin was right
next to me pig pin was yeah a former
Marine too like myself indeed yeah we
were both on the floor the and these two
lieutenants had just come in they'd been
in Vietnam for two weeks and they were
being assigned waiting to be ass signed
and there one goes to the window I
holler down get your dumb ass out that
window and then they blew up the
enlisted Barracks next door right and
all that [__] that was the listed
Transit Barracks no they we were in
transi it was a permanent party okay
it's where the commo guys at oh yeah g
Pew and them yeah yeah Pew was uh and
Bobby Leathers yeah they were all in
that one there because the when we went
outside the camp Pew and those guys were
out fighting yeah and it was a it was
typical of an attack with
no leadership on our end right it was
all these little battles going on the
Recon sections down there fighting and I
was up in the you know the rimp section
up there with the guys right and part of
that uh which led to the lethality of
that night was the NVA and the Recon
company cuz that's where they wanted to
hurt us the most they had machine guns
set up there were three rows of Barracks
of um Recon Special Forces and they had
three rows of U hooches set up and each
row at the end there was a machine gun
on both ends so they knew that when the
attack was launched the SF men would
come out of hooches and they gunned them
down and the first one was one of the
first was U William brick yeah the third
yeah I put him in a body bag yes me and
and he came out and got gunned down as
did several others well it was you know
going back to the original stuff that
happened to me cuz oh I can you know
this is your story it's well all combat
it's like you you mentioned to me and
it's very true two people could be
sitting together in in a firefight and
after you debrief them they only saw
what they saw they can't see what I saw
yeah you know so you're you get these
mixed me people start saying well I
didn't see that well [__] no you were up
the other end of the camp how could you
see it different bunch of people but you
know that kid that went in and was
trying to get to uh write a paper on I
think it was a disseration their
attack I you made contact with him he
had some really good information he got
from the NBA side of the house that how
many people cuz we had a p camp next to
us right north of fob4 and they had
planned to go in to breach it to get
more troops to support them they did
they went in there but the problem was
they couldn't get through their wire you
know they had to wire to keep people in
and then one of the men called in an air
strike from um one of the Cobra gunships
that showed up and killed a lot of them
in the wire well they had that was the
crazy thing about it they had these damn
gunships running over us and we're
running all over the camp you know and
our guys in their underwear and yeah and
[__] like that and the only reason I I
had my tager fatigue pants cuz I'd been
in quesan you never you know yeah ready
to go in the trench line and I had since
I give spider my my swed C or he could
go be do go to the uh downtown house 22
won't break his cover story for command
sord major but uh he he didn't he didn't
go down there on a on a mission he did
not he went down there a little
self-gratification with the young ladies
and stuff down there but getting back to
F be before
Sergeant so
anyhow it just like it said in the book
luckily conin was on a Recon team at and
he had his car 15 and grenades and stuff
the two lieutenants remember the old
deal you go into their try they give you
those damn carbin right M2 carbin they
still had their m2s they had their m2s
and they had no ammo
[Music]
no so they're in they're in there and
they're looking at me and and and spider
had been in there first of course he
took off on me and we went me and conin
and of course I knew Colin for years and
he was in the Marine Corps too so we had
that facility they showed an outside
movie there always and and they they
showed this movie that I'll never forget
it remember the Truman capot book in
Cold Blood indeed that they showed them
the night of the attack the night of the
attack yeah cold blood and I I never
been a drinker as you as you know yeah
no and uh so any I I I want to get some
sleep man cuz I've been up flying all
day and all this [__] and spider with
the party and uh conin was with me he he
he you know he we sat there and
bullshitted in in the room and went to
bed and I always slept with a pistol
pillow anyhow so when this all this [__]
happened and I you know the zapper comes
down the hole and you know with a pistol
at night it's a hey you roster you know
right and you're not at that time you
weren't really thrilled about your
pistol skills you're a car 15 guy I am a
car 1550 you and me both fully automatic
he G gives up to all my goddamn
Marksmanship skills yeah so I just shot
I just shot at his goddamn crotch are
and hit him in the
head and he fell he fell out the door I
which I didn't know cuz I got blown back
into the room and I had a concussion my
nose is bleeding my and the ears and
everything and I told uh I told the one
Lieutenant it wasn't hit wasn't hurt the
other guy had a big chunk out his arm a
piece of rapel came through and hit him
from the explosion and next bar and
Barracks are blown up all around us
there's far fight down in the T area and
you know and the only thing that saved
us was there they started shooting
flares off the Marines on the other side
third am track on the other side they
were being probed too right and they
started shooting 81 mm flares and they
that kind of light L but the bad thing
was we're all running around and you
know looking like
zappers and uh if I I told I told uh Joe
I says man I only going you know we're
not going to die in this hoot let's get
out and do it so we went next door where
the building been blown up is all blown
up you know sh [__] there guys were
wounded there were two guys laying in
there in their underwear didn't have any
stuff and I told Joe I said well you got
the car 15 and stuff take this well then
one of them was named Hoffman he was a
radio operator right I knew him when I
was at four and he says and he saw me
and he says
uh Bob scully's laying over there too
who is way wounded and Bob sco is one of
our aling medicine F3 he was a senior
medic senior medic okay yeah and uh
living legend as far as you know and
Special Forces absolutely and me and Bob
been friends for
years so I says okay I'll go over there
and get Scully come back Joe yeah and
help me so he said well once you come
with me then we'll go and I says I'm
this is not a debate in society get your
ass get these guys down and he okay so
anyhow I went over there and I zapper
come around the building and I shot him
right were you 45 yeah we my 4 he didn't
have any weapon all he had was grenades
hanging all over him those chicom
grenades and he had a satchel
charge he just wearing a loin cloth he
had the uh yeah the B that across it
Banda it said we come to die and they
did me and yeah we you know we killed
over 75 of them in WoW but any now I
shot him and I looking for his weapon I
thought he had an AK and at least I'd
have a goddamn gun yeah yeah and the
first thing that hit me own of was godam
a son of all the dumb things that think
of so anyhow he didn't have it all he
had is I guess that's the reason he
didn't be probably trying to De him out
out of the camp so shot him that I I I
heard the screaming and over by the
lutrine area was somebody laying there
screaming and it was
Scully and there was another body over
here and it was another medic it was
with him with Scully they killed him and
so I I say [__] all this flares coming
to you all the buildings blow I started
crawling out there to him and Scully I
says I'm coming Bob I'll be there and he
say no no no they're just using me his
bait and uh that's when the zapper was
behind the generator the big generator
right he raised up from the generator
and started shooting at me and uh he was
about to good a shot with his AK as I
was with a 45 so luckily I survived it
and the only thing that saved me Colin
come back because he had dropped those
guys off with that lieutenant in the
Jeep right yeah it was was driving the
jeep I think it was Blanket ship blanket
ship there was Blanket ship yeah were
picking up people yeah you know under
all this stuff he was out driving a Jeep
picking up wounded and he saw he pinned
a Zapp her down Joe did is that right
yeah so I told him I said well keep him
down and he says he says okay I'll keep
him down well just then the [__]
stands up behind the God and throws a
hand grenade at
us and I throw my I throw myself over
Scully and we both got shrapnel on our
legs hit our legs
so Colin's shooting at him and he's
shooting more generator than he is him
so I just started firing I hit him right
in the jaw and spun him around and Colin
hit him and he fell down and so I we got
and then Henderson doc Henderson Rosco
Henderson right these guys all slept in
the same Barracks get all the Medics did
and you know how he fed her don't you
only by name yeah hoe was there too he
was an fob for medic and he was a quan
with
me anyhow he came craw that they'd all
been together and they couldn't get out
the Scully because they kept shooting at
them every time they all they had the
bait the whole bait fact they had they
had their M2 medical things they have no
weapons yeah typical I se Medics man you
know God damn it you know so we got
Scully we took I said God we got to
carry them across here and Joe says what
are we going to Joe says I why don't we
take the door off of him the hooches
were blown up so we went over and got
the door and we put him on the door and
Scully a big kid you know guy and uh he
was in the John Wayne movie you know the
Green Beret he was the medic on on that
de I heard that yeah so anyhow we put
him on the damn thing and he's screaming
so I got my hand over his mouth and like
we given our position away with all this
[__] happening and went [__] so I
we're starting to carry him hend
Henderson and me are carrying him Joe's
the point man on the deal right you know
and you're heading to the dispensary we
no we're going to the Jeep Joe had the
jeep weight okay had the jeep weight and
we only like you know 20 met away but
hell Under Fire sh they shooting off a
marble Mountain at us yeah and all that
crap and mortar rounds coming in and you
know it was it was something out of a
John Wayne movie indeed yeah so we got
to the was come around the corner and
two zappers came around the corner of
this
building so I got my 45 laying on the on
the on the door door litter and and
Joe's got his AK so I'm and we drop we
drop
Scully oh no and you got that open head
wound I can see gry matter yeah yeah and
I wouldn't give my you know he had more
of him but the old say don't give
morphine to a head wound you like all
right so I placed a pistol up and we
started shooting at him we hit one of
them and they took off you know he
didn't hit him bad enough he left but
then I found out later uh he we hit him
through the hand he lost he lost his
hand joea he hit him he emptied the
goddamn car at right so we got to the
Jeep and put Scully on the Jeep and
Holland and then were still in it the
other guys we picked up out of the
barracks right and so there the guy
driving the jeep says do you need to go
with it with me and I said no and I he
says and Henderson said are you sure and
and I said why he said he said God
you're covered with blood you're you're
all hit and I was running off adrenaline
you know it was like oh yeah I knew it
had been hit but it was like yeah rpel
yeah it wasn't nak around you know no so
we did we started back I said well let's
let's go back to the uh they had the
officer's Barracks there and it had been
blown up
too and it it had been blown up too so
we head back there and come around the
come around the corner of that and this
guy jumps out of the out of debris of
the blown up listed barracks right
yeah and I looked and he was wearing the
breach cloth and stuff it was in
zapper and uh somebody hollered in burs
there's a bad guy out there don't watch
yourself watch yourself there's a bad
guy out there and
was and I was one of the it was a one of
the uh radio operators was still in the
in the in the debris and every time he
moved this guy would shoot at
him well he jumped up and I empty my 45
at him and conin was behind me and he
couldn't get a shot at him cuz I was
you're in the way I'm in the way but I
hit him twice with 45 and and knocked
him down and hit him through the throat
and uh the arm and the leg a good shot
pattern so anyhow
he he was laid there dying you know and
I Colin so I'm going to finish I said
not let him suffer no hell so we picked
got the Met got the guy out from me he
said where you Sav my life I said we
ain't got time to ding this
[__] so I picked up his AK this guy's AK
and I says [__] now I got know got a
weapon [__] yeah this pistol could go
so I get the guy I pulled out give him
my 45 and I come back and get it next
day and uh so I had to say okay I come
around the building and Joe is in front
of me thank God somebody hollered are
you Americans are you Americans and and
Joe says yeah yeah
yeah he says I almost shot you I seen a
guy with the
AK it was Colonel Smith and sard major
Stratton from fob2 they were up there
for that board that for the board they
hung out for the night yeah they hung
out there to party oh my God and they
had two wounded guys with them yeah and
they you know they were
confused like most Colonels are and uh
he looked looked at me and he says he
says who's in charge of this everybody
pointed her finger at me and I says I
said well you can't stay here Colonel I
said you're in a field of fire here and
all this shit's happening he said well
what's your suggestion I said I'm going
to move you over to this latrine and we
can secure the latrine I got a medic
with me with Henderson he had his Aid
bag and we'll take care of these guys
here and he said well that sound like a
good idea and I oh said well no [__]
[__] so sir sir by your Le sir so
anyhow moved moved these guys one of
them was ambulatory and the other one
was and the other guy was fall [__] up
man he' been blown up in the building oh
and I had splinters you know all from
the wood and [__] so we drug him over
there and Henderson was there and taking
care of
him so I looked at conin and I said well
let's see if we can find some more
people we moving back here and this will
be a tree treeage right and uh Smith
Smith says well watch yourself walking
around with that AK and I says yeah yeah
I got a little paranoid in you know so
might shoot me with
it so anyhow we we pleased up a couple
other people and brought them back there
and then we it was starting to get Dawn
by that time by that time and the sun
was coming and [__] still going on yeah
this is after a couple hours oh three
hours just constant [__] and then the P
Camp's being hit and all that shit's
happening over there gunships running
all over and I said oh hope they just
start shooting at us and Larry trembles
up top up on top of knock knocked the
mort out he knocked the mort out he
saved a lot of lives by doing that
absolutely and the Marines had him over
to the Amtrak had the club sure cuz he
had saved that 106 crew was up there he
he knocked out those they had a big part
I said God damn the Marine cor off as
army guys come to their Club this must
been a really big deal well you know
what had happened too what was the final
part of that was they uh the next day
they went down policed up who they
killed and there was a uh the NVA had a
Ruck and in The Rock was more plans to
attack the Marine the following day and
so the kingp came up and took out the
one zero to go down yeah and they
handled off and they were able to notify
the Marines about the a follow-up attack
yeah he took the Ruck with him yeah yeah
and then then cuz Larry stayed up on the
mountain well the rest of the little
people wanted to leave yeah they W they
started down the mountain and the NVA
was still up there and started shooting
and they decided to come back with Larry
and Larry talks don't if you go down you
might run into NBA they went down they
ran NBA but at least they they took out
the mortar oh yeah NBA Mort saved the
lives of the camp it was uh you know we
we got the people over that have been
wounded and stuff over to the dispensary
and it was a mad house you know right
every tell you the truth the one doctor
we had he'd been wounded too oh was that
right yeah he was in there treating
people and all the Medics were you know
most of them you know had strap on and
stuff sure and there was that Lieutenant
was at the back door the one you know
with the but I can't think his I didn't
know him he's sitting there with with
his car 15 sitting Travis Mills Travis
Mills he's sitting there in a chair and
there's blood all over him and Travis
Mills had been shot five times five
times earlier in the evening yeah and he
was guarding the back door he came in
they did the triea and said you're not
going to die here guard the back door
guard the back and he sat there but he
saw him he was sitting in a chair at the
back door just covered with blood then I
get and Howry feder was in there doing a
tra on a Vietnamese guy
killed and I went over there and I and
at then I I left I said I told I told TR
uh conin I says well let's go out and
see if we can you know help some more
that's when I run into
spider [__] he he hijacked a goddamn
3/4 ton truck and got a bunch of guys
together and came back yeah and uh they
came in he's out there by Pat Pat
I come up to me he looks at me and he
says godamn it you look bad and I said
where's my goddamn Swedish K well also I
think so we can move on with the story
but before we do there's two things one
at one point they came to you and said
you should be treated for your wounds
here twice and you said no I'll go
somewhere else because there are so many
wounded people what happened was uh
there was a Navy uh Corman he came in he
came down from the there was a naval
hospital down the road yes sir that's of
course the Marine Corp gets all their
goddamn Medical Care from the Navy their
Corman sure they wear Marine Corps
uniforms and their FMF
Corman so
anyhow those guys were coming down like
the guy you you know that right Harry
yeah Harry from California isn't he yes
chapter 78 SFA chapter he uh he was down
there with he these guys were TR
reporting you know wounded back and
forth to the field hospital all while
under enemy fire oh yeah we were still
hell we were killing zappers in the
morning you know that two ran into the
[__] house and blew theirselves up so
I'm standing I got all that and they
thought I was being metac next thing I
know I'm on the Jeep going down to the
damn hospital and spider's looking for
me still cuz we were you know we got
shot at and we were behind a black label
beer can right yeah yeah they were
shooting at us off
marble round's going into the beer and
it's coming down on
us and then anyhow I got down there and
of course these you know they had all
these Cas the Marines are taking
[__] and we had people and the the
Marines on the other side were in
contact there was you know there were uh
a battalion of BC and NBA that were hit
in total yeah hitting all the different
bases of over 300 so in order for us to
move on with our sawc version of the
story 46 years
later um you received an award and
decoration for that night which was uh
the distinguished service cross indeed
it was well earned I had to at least get
that only because the enlisted men I
served with that night one out of M
spider parks and Joe conin and and Dicky
bird Crawford right and and met another
from Al B3 another M Chase MADD from Al
B3 uh I was at the reunion when and they
asked me you know do you ever get your
decoration from from for and I says yeah
I got two purple
hearts and uh they were on this Mission
mostly led by spider to uh give me and
and Crawford having the contacts that he
developed uh he knew the right way to
put in for all this [__] you know and
they working with Neil Thorne too Neil
was a grocer writer for a lot Ray wrote
up my decoration right R Cal Ray Calif
and Colonel bar signed off on it all and
being a full Colonel that didn't hurt no
and I had uh I had uh five eyewitness
statements so that is an award well
earned so this is August 68 now you've
been in country just about 8 months
months and two months later you were you
were a key participant in yet another
major battle where a nine-man Recon team
on October 5th 1968 gets inserted into a
Target there's an
inexperienced team leader who remain
nameless he goes in and the second
helicopter comes in with Lyn black who
had a previous tour Duty with the
173rd and um this was his first mission
with St Alabama he was a radio operator
and he was the radio operator and they
had a couple in-country practice
missions where the previous one Tim
schof who was experienced highly
respected but the other sergeant had
more rank he's the team leader bottom
line they get into a Target LM black
says we should leave they saw an NVA
flag which indicates at least a
battalion or reg what's what's they're a
regiment like the Marine Corp with their
B their brigades a regiment this is
regular army talk what does that mean in
terms of Body Count 3,000 well it does
one of the things that an NBA division
consisted of 8,000 you know and the NBA
General told ly had 10 so they could
have been reinforced right too but the
you know like the Marine Corps uh a
regiment in the Marine Corps is is uh
6,000 so the point is when they landed
they thought it was at least 3,000 enemy
troops L said we should leave the inex
Sergeant says no worse he ran him down a
trail walked him into an ambush he was
killed a good point man was killed
immediately another indid was wounded
they have a firefight so this is every
started first thing in the morning yeah
he was wounded a little bit later with a
hand grenade that knocked him out his
cloth and um and I'm above him flying
cuby so when you get there you and
spider take turns cuz they're in all we
working so much T that's why and so
there are some key moments for you
during that battle when you're in the
air you're seeing what's going on in the
ground you have bad weather you also get
smoked with all the ordinance and
there's a couple of moments you had
there nightfalls coming too well this is
after a day of battle when at at key
points where the team was on the ground
they killed so many NV that they were
stacking up the dead bodies and firing
at the next wave attack behind what wall
of dead bodies to this day I think the
only reason they they didn't kill them
was they were trying to draw helicopters
and shoot them down I think so for more
for the bait Factor oh yeah they could
have killed those and we had the the
classic example of a of a king be that
came in for a resupply yeah he got you
and made it they said po the smoke and
the NVA popped the same smoke that ly
black well they didn't identify the old
process right you know always identify
well they both popped the same color
they guessed at that anyway they lost a
king be yeah well they lost a king be a
resupply king be and then we couldn't we
we tried to
get support from the King bees to come
and pick the team up we had no gun ding
gun support until J uh judging execution
came up and they saved the day cuz we
were down to you know these guys were
just fighting and they had at least two
sorties that day right well they had
they were flying so low that they had
tree limbs hanging off their strike
no yeah wow so this is a judgeing
execution from the 176 the muskets they
lived with us they lived with us that be
one and they also lived with us first
time I met those guys who were duck they
stayed a month with us up there and they
were just amazing sh for hot they they
had a siren on the helicopter and they
pulled a siren when they come in a gun
run for gunun gun runs now the thing was
on that whole the whole deal was if the
Air Force
hadn't committed to Jolly greens right
that we would have never got those guys
no no tell you the truth I've become
very pessimistic at the when we we lost
the engine and stuff we weren't going to
get so explain about your personal loss
of an engine that's one of the points I
wanted to get to you've been on the
scene I forget how many times you and
spider rotated back and forth and get
refuel and get more uh Rockets So during
your second or third refuel you and
second one yeah okay and spider was
getting ready to go back but they' had
that F4 almost hit him right and they'd
had the rocket pods actually ripped off
the goddamn crack and so and the wings
were all wobbled and spider like you
were you two were both in O2 CNAs yeah
it's a push poool aircraft right
observation aircraft by Design it's It's
a 65 35 front engine 35 power and the
rear is 60 okay and so but the key point
was you observed an an F4 almost coll
with oh yeah and the pro the propar from
that aircraft was so severe that it
knocked off the uh pods that were on the
they caught the exhaust of that F4 right
okay that's what because he saw them and
tried to evade them and of course the
slow flying oh2 and a God damn jet mock
jet at the most mil he made a gun run so
he was in you know yeah get out of the
the burners yeah cuz they were shooting
12.7 so you observed that oh yeah yeah
[__] I thought and then how soon I
thought what the first thing came to my
mind God damn it I'm going to be the
only cover writer
after cuz by that time both you and
spider had been promoted to a cvy rider
and a cvy rider in our tactic situation
I recruit the spider indeed but the
point is to the unique sock side of this
story
was that when we had Air Force pilots
they would fly but we had experienced
one zeros that would be a cuy rider as
you know that was the PR but for our
viewers the pr why yeah well the
prerequisite was that you had ground
time as a leader and you understood
Tactical Air support and movement of
troops on the ground to help them evade
and and be able to get to lzs because
our our our mission was a team on the
ground where a Pilots mission was the
ordinance and the aircraft that came to
support it so our whole mission me and
spider and Dallas Long Street and you
know John pler right all the guys who
flew cby in in Vietnam Don wlin papy we
Walton took my place you I recruited him
too and he didn't want to do it
but yeah he's my one zero I know it he
just didn't want the responsibility he
wanted to run you know running was okay
but he saw what me and Spider went
through you know we couldn't sleep at
night and [__] we after going out and
you know getting in that goddamn plane
and starting all over again oh yeah and
uh but anyhow uh yeah there was a lot of
close calls that night and the and and
the you know the big thing was this was
a true inner
Service uh activity absolutely and the
only thing we didn't have we had Marine
Core gunships come out even sure we had
Scarface there Scarface came out uh the
lead helicopter pilot that got uh L out
finally got them out a Jolly Green Giant
yeah was a coast guard pilot was an
exchange oh that's right I forgot about
that it was a coast guard P Exchange
program this is he FL air rescue for the
helicopter for the and Coast Guard yeah
Coast Guard he volunteered the to go
into uh the Jolly greens and again that
jolly green rescued Lyn after another
jolly green was shot down King was shot
down well we had two King and they had
two survivors we had two King be shot
down right and we had two survivors off
the down yeah uh J green Caspar the PG
right and uh the co- pilot the co- pilot
and so near the end of the day this
jolly green comes in and hovers and is
able to pull the team out well the first
one that came in the one that got shot
down yeah they they l a jungle
penetrator you know that's how they they
don't land they pen because they
couldn't land there well their mission
is down Pilots right we became they
never had supported a SOG team this the
was that one the first time they did
that they ever did it in in ashow and E
I didn't realize that yeah first time
they'd ever done it and they have to
commit to do it and they have a they I
found this out later because we me and
Spider went up there you know f up there
to dang dang yeah to the uh their
unit and their thing is once their
commited they'll fly to every aircraft
shot down or they pick them up it's you
know good these guys that are best well
and the model for the jolly green Giants
That Others May Live yeah and there are
good men that have died living up they
armor plating on the bottom right of it
and they don't have a door gunner they
had the same thing they the they have a
mechanic it's called a mechanic which is
their crew chief right and he's got an
M16 with 30 round magazine too yeah and
they finally put Min guns on them later
on oh sure and they had a PJ and every
helicopter at a PJ par uh or
paratroopers and outstanding troops yeah
and I told you about Caspar he killed
himself later on committed suicide but
uh yeah he went you know as we know some
people can handle but even there like
the armor planting Lynn talked about how
when they were coming out they felt the
the
uh RPGs hitting the bottom and giving
the helicopter surges well the first one
the one that got shot down yeah I'd put
it in we'd Run Gun runs everything you
know cuz they were surrounded it oh yeah
I mean we were taking 12 point point you
know it was it was chaotic at the best
and he went in and lowed the jungle
penetrator and Lynn was Lyn and taking
over the team he was the one too right
the you know the one what and the other
American froze on him for the whole day
just he prayed a lot he didn't fire one
round his his father was a general
general of course yeah yeah we and Lyn
saved that team I mean Lyn and cowboy
yeah you know who else was I'll tell you
something about Cowboy though and they
had do I had to get him off the damn
radio was that right yeah God he got on
the radio and Lynn started taking over
and he's talking to me and he's kept
saying mandolin mandolin we don't die we
don't die my Cod name is mandolin yeah
and he's you know I finally I said
Cowboy God dang it I got enough to worry
about we're going to get you out and and
it was that helicopter at jolly green
was hovering there and all of a sudden I
seen a start taking hits and the and and
the engine well the flame started coming
out of it no yeah and he tried to break
off to get away right you know and he
just curved and he hit it tree and stuff
and he turned upside down and crashed
into the jungle and I'll never forget
this Greg harness I was with him he went
oh you know we're all oh of course oh
[__] and you're viewing such tragedy and
not only that the team's done there's no
way we're going to get these guys out of
here if we lost a Jolly Jolly Green and
the thing was there was another one
right there oh yeah yeah that's the one
with the Coast Guard follow sure and
they had another one that had been shot
up bad that had he took 7 hits and he
went in and landed at the 101st Outpost
at uh eagle nest Eagles Nest yeah yeah
he he could make it back there so
anyways you survived that day and this
is one of your two days later we were on
the ground engaged for four hours but
compared to what Lyn black went through
oh you were in oral [__] too we were a
little bit deep but you and spider were
there directed us got us through it all
and uh I'm here today thanks to you and
the Air Force and everybody else you
know yeah it was a team ofair you know
that's one thing about sag
I thought I always said that uh sag was
an instrumental in
Socom because we've always had this
thing about you know the Marine Corps we
can do our own thing Army we can do our
of course the Army we rely on the Air
Force because there are tactical err
sure and stuff and transport there's
always been this there's never been this
uh you know this this closeness of
services that we work together and sag
was because it was a cross the service
outfit absolutely and uh you know I mean
we use Marine air we well back at Bas
there would be the inter service rivalry
the Air Force would be on the Army and
we' all insult the Marine Corps but when
we went across the fence was all
business well there was like us versus
you know that famous story when we were
up at fob4 we went down there to get
that Swift boats Jo yeah sure and went
into at Chuli went in there to because
we were going to do swiftbolt operations
right God there wasn't enough [__] now
they're going to do swiftbolt operations
so anyhow walk by this this barish me
and SP me and spider and and the this
sign on is go Navy beat the Army he was
just before close to the Army Navy game
Army Navy game and this guy was out
throwing the football a Navy a Navy
officer yeah and this guy was a was a
second class Clerk Navy wor what they
are they and this stuff and I looked at
this guy I spiders is texting of course
of course I says does that guy look
familiar to you and spider says God damn
it that's Roger stall back yeah in July
in Jui throw a football he went through
the Academy of course course and he
volunteered to go to n he he was a he
was the Quarter Master officer there at
juuli so we I said godamn it me and
spider football players like you you
know I says you you're were survivors of
the football games on that's right we
run me and me and me and and and and the
carrot was getting a fight every got oh
yeah and we BR we almost broke John
Walton's ankle and they made us quit
that was the most severe injury was a
foot injury from the football
game so anyhow he had big feet man oh
yeah God he had big hands too yeah went
over and he says uh he was a lieutenant
JG he says Lieutenant I says are you
Roger St back and he says he said what
are you guys he said well typical spider
he says I'd like to tell you sir but
we'd have to kill
you he started laughing he said are you
Marines said no we're special forces and
he says oh yeah okay and spider says hey
will you throw the ball to us so we had
to catch the ball me and him from yeah
you had some good passes yeah oh yeah
from stall back it was it was funny
though you could you go in you know I
got to be good friends with Maggie Ray
of course because she was back over
there let me get back to Roger for a
second because we had a little mention
on the ground Roger didn't you call him
up I him yeah and uh we talked about he
didn't remember specific but said yeah I
had football there we pass with anybody
who come by yeah we were R friend yeah
and uh and spider was a quarterback you
know God he could throw a ball oh yeah
he pitched on our baseball team you know
yeah and he pitched on our a company
softball team we were undefeated that
year yeah we beat every team we went and
pred the prisons Walpole prison and all
them and H spider well this is one of
those little CBS I really enjoyed
because you you turn to him and you said
someday I'll tell my children and
grandchildren I tossed around the
football with a Heisman Trophy winner
and Ro rer stach responded the real
Heralds in Vietnam are special forces
troops such as you and your friends and
I look forward to someday telling my
children I threw passes to a US Army
Special Forces Soldier yeah that was so
cool that Wonder little moments in time
you know it was and it was so the first
thing out of spider's mouth I'm from
Texas he didn't tell me and did starback
said well I won't hold that again
yeah and he didn't tell him he was Park
kamanche yeah yeah yeah yeah God his
father died in prison yeah yeah one of
those stories but he was he speaks like
seven or eight languages God I told you
when we were up there in Rose's Medal of
Honor thing yeah those two hookers come
in and they were both Ukrainian right of
course and they're talking back and I'm
I'm there with uh with Beaver McAn and
his wife his wife's Ty and and eddan and
their boy and and and spiders stand
there looking at him and they're
chatting back and forth and spider jumps
right in with him starts speaking
Russian to him yeah I looked at him like
uh and and there SF guys from the from
the uh from the seventh group there were
there his escort guys they were all
watching and they they moved up towards
them and this one Mass started to come
back and said what' you say to them and
spider
says you got to learn the
languages
Spiderman he's an intellectual oh he got
a PhD he did on top of that so let's get
back to Pat Watkins the verse so your
tour Duty ends your first tour Duty you
survive it you go back to 10th group
Special Forces Group where you and I uh
reconnected a little bit later in 1969
for a few months and I went back to
Vietnam in October then what did you do
from 10th group you went to where cuz
10th group was just you had parades and
some training yeah I volunteered to go I
went down to see Mrs a like you did oh
did you oh yeah oh I didn't know that
yeah me and Jo Alderman uhhuh and Fred
zabowski Fred went down yeah he had them
and this is after he earned the Medal of
Honor he wanted to go back to n you know
Fred of course and of course Miss why I
met Fred after the war I met oh okay on
the phone we talked on the phone several
times okay yeah you being from New
Jersey you can understand both from
Trenton yeah he's one of five Trenton
six Trentonian that served in Sag yeah I
know you that is funny you your
quarterback you guys are both quarter my
high school quarterback Kia February 69
in in
Cambodia yeah and what crosy what it was
we I wanted to go to okanawa I want to
get out of anything to was State side
and there wasn't a war going on and
being screwed with all all the time and
you did a lot of parades in I remember
you were so unhappy with parade funerals
you had I had the colors and I had
funeral details I I planted more
pilgrims
in in Massachusetts New Hampshire and
Vermont H we were we were burying this
this [__] Colonel World War II guy on
a hillside in Vermont up by sto up by
the ski ski area and was been snowing
and it was cold and and we had a we took
a chapl was method chapl was and he
pissed him on all the way up there
because he was they taking him out of
the service he's getting a parish in in
North
Dakota and he was a captain you know in
there in the Army and he was living the
good life his wife lived in officer
quarters and stuff so anyhow we're up
there and I'll never forget this I had I
my uh radio operate my radio oper my
medic uh Pete hanberg he was a from
Boston right he had two silver stars he
was he was with Clyde when Clyde got DSC
that's the reason I yeah so anyhow
moving right along yeah so anyhow and
hell of a godd dam mic and we got the
we're on the side and we they got
plywood down you know the gave gravide
and we got jump boots on you know those
damn things are not good for anything
braids you know no he's standing there
and next thing does he slips and goes
under the coffin no into the grave site
and the wife's out there and she's you
know she's my age now and she's out
there and she starts wailing and this
young priest that was doing the you know
the the ceremony at the at the grave
site and he was trying to keep a
straight face all he was talking to me
he he was going to go skiing that
afternoon stole and I want to get over
with and and we're over trying to figure
out how they get beat out of the Grave
oh my God so any he pull he's got mud
all over and [__] and pulled him out of
then guy had the fire Squad too you know
we had to and we always put them out of
sight yeah and what we did we we had
this thing we' take rounds it wasn't the
ones we used course and we'd brass them
put them inside the flag sure to present
it to the so so I mean so you know
you're trying to would be seven seven
shell casings or seven rounds uh you
have seven b yeah man we give seven
rounds in there but they were pry we did
it before we left we took some brass and
shined it up sure part of the ceremony
so any you get him out there and all
this family and everybody's around his
wife just wailing oh God and I said oh
God I'm going to hear about this when I
get back to Devon 7 and the funeral
director he was a good guy too we went
to the funeral home the night before we
stayed there overnight and uh he was
doing an Al he was doing
a he was bombing guy in the basement
down in he said you guys want to come
down here and I said no I've seen her
enough dead
bodies he that's only your first tour
yeah and he says well you don't want to
see the all I have seen so any that was
that was a a a cassic deal so anyways
you go down and see Bill Alexander you
wind up going back to Vietnam yeah no no
no first group I went to first group
God my wife would have killed me if I
Vol go back vietn now now I went to the
first group because I want to get out of
devans yeah and uh what happened and
then Joel Alderman he got he they were
forming the ranger battalions right he
wanted to go the ranger battalions you
you know he was like Tommy shook Mr
Ranger you know sure sure and he had two
silver stars at koune and Joe Shi for
hot yeah yeah so anyhow and then Fred
want to go to
Vietnam he miss a that's when I told you
we were walking down the hallway trying
to find Mrs A9 cor is I know that
feeling up been there yeah you you get
lost in the damn Pentagon in a minute oh
yeah all these wings and all this stuff
so anyhow we walking down the hall we
all got our War suits on you know and I
had the lowest decorations of these two
and walking down and we're all Masters
we're all e7s at the time and Fred's got
the metal you know the metal Baby Blue
with the five star on indeed and he's
coming down the hallway and this
Brigadier General is coming up the other
way dar diamond doesen oh yeah the
puzzle Palace yeah right and he sees us
and he
says God damn it's Kennedy's
rifles
no I never heard that before me either
yeah Kennedy's rifles and and Fred
looked at him and he says you're damn
right sir and don't you owe me a salute
yeah and he looked over and saw the [__]
and he said you're damn right sergeant
and saluted him and that's a tradition
anybody me you don't have to but it's a
traditional thing you're saluting the
metal not the man indeed and but anyhow
it was so funny he
says H I won't ask you guys youve seen
much
combat all of a sudden there were two
purple WS all right so moving right
along so you get back to first group
Fred comes along with you or what what
Fred then no no no they told Fred he
couldn't go right because he had the
medal that's right so
then Fred was having you know life
problems like you always did and uh he
he kind of you know he got tired of
being drugg around to all these this
pump and circum stuff which metal VOR
wers end up doing lot of yes a lot of
but the only ones that get away when not
doing is the officers you just say I'm
not going to do it and so anyhow make a
long story short he went to Oki too
right okay so I'm I go into Charlie
Company second Battalion and the sard
major is har Harris no yeah from fob1
and see and F4 he' been my S case and
the bter and Viet been me so I walk in
there and he says
I'm going to put you on the team and I
says okay I said don't put me on one
these speci because I was Halo scuba
sure I said I don't want to put up with
that you know just just going out and
looking for lobster [__] diving and
stuff or jumping on weekends you know
per I said I just want to be on an A
Team he says well I got an an old s guy
he's team sergeant and you can be the
Intel Sergeant I said said who is it
squirrel sprous no yeah so any he had
that to you a squirrel and there were
four of us guys s guys on that team no
kidding yeah so we what happened was
they had those snake bite missions down
south and that would be a six uh month
rotation oh it was three three by that
time that was three and what you
basically were doing was just they were
sticking a lot of them on Hatchet forces
and stuff and so you eventually you wind
up going back when and with what
happened was my wife hadn't got there
yet right there was always this quarters
quarter stuff getting quarters and stuff
so uh I got ConEd into Joe
Walker really yeah those guys Lonnie Pam
all these guys are volunteering to go
back they they got me in the bad
situation I said okay I'll go back so I
got there and those guys no they all
went on they were conton guys Joe guy
Joe of Legend yeah he'd run 30 missions
that you know he was a popup T and he
looked like Dr peepers you know he his
glasses little glasses and stuff Skitty
guy you never know he's Natural Born
Killer you know and I got there and they
say God damn it we need a covery
writer so I Luke will be for for the U
mission for bu was a was a uh running
the laun site at the quantry quantry
laun site so you flew coffee during your
second tour I threw it for a month and a
half and then they said they needed one
zero former one zeros and stuff for the
Thundercloud program which was the NBA
deals we to basically give them uh SF
training how to communicate and all this
and how to contact eror and stuff so
they sent me down to dang to that L F6
where they had the training center oh
down HT H they sent me down there and I
[__] kicked they told me they told me
well you you got to get back to you got
to get back to uh o Oki and I saids okay
so I get back there and Carol they
wanted me there cuz my wife had shown up
with two kids yeah and and and so anyhow
I got back there and got quarters and
all this [__] got settled and I was down
in the Philippines with with on team we
were on this so-called Civic action
mission right but we were setting up
safe houses and because they were
fighting the hu down there in the the
Muslim deal yes and Nick Nick Ro was in
charge of doing everything no kidding
yeah he was you were there when he was
kidnapped killed no I left when he got
killed but he was doing it through the
state department know right the state
department directorate yeah he was he'
he'd come back he was the uh he told me
he ran for political office in Texas and
was a tra State Treasurer no yeah Nick
was funny funny guy great guy yeah God
the [__] he did when he was captured
well yeah he trained a hawk to get food
no yeah he trained a hawk and he'd go
out and and this is Nick row who was a a
Green Beret P for five years the first
one yeah the two guys with him were
killed they shot him yeah yeah Bassie
and forberg right as a retaliation for
the NBA BC I mean the Arvin would done
to during cat no shooting yeah prisoners
and [__] you know oh yeah so anyhow uh
Nick was running the operation and we
were supp it was typhoon went through
there we we were down with an
engineering unit M and we're were
supposed to be building help build
schools so I the captain had in charge
he got rifted while we was there Captain
Nash they were riting all the and a RI
is a reduction of force as the
Vietnamization program he' been in
Vietnam two k in so basically in Vietnam
they were reducing the number of troops
in country so there's a reduction of
force and this is a rift when people
would be demoted stay had to get out
well they give some people choices some
yeah not all yeah like conin was a
captain when he got RI he went back to
E7 they they let the guys who were
senior n's and stuff go back like they
try to get me and spider take
commissions but there was no guarantee
now spider could have held it because he
had a degree at the time right I
couldn't I didn't have a degree they
tried foai they tried to get us so then
let's move forward to your third tour
Duty will you R up running missions this
time was at CCS yeah that this is near
the end of cuz sag was an 8 years from
64 until 72 your third tour Duty you
return to Vietnam again with another
snake bite team out of First Press
Forces Group sign a SOG and you wind up
on a Recon team or doing recon there
well little more about that the second
on my third tour I was on I was in the
first group right I'd volunteer go back
again sure cuz that was good Duty and by
now it's 72 it's a 71 7 okay and I got
orders this is so funny too I I me I got
orders and and Butch Fernandez a friend
of mine who was in he was a senior
instructor in ricondo school in Vietnam
his first he's Awan he's a kid I told
you yeah there was a Portuguese Hawaiian
Fernandez everybody thought he's a
Mexican he used to always give that you
know cers up [__] every time somebody
say something to so anyhow butching but
and me were got orders he come down and
says have you got orders go back now I
says yeah I got to get my wife and he
had his wife there lay on the island two
and two kids and he said well I'm I'm
not he said what's the orders for and I
says godam I got to go back to
brag he said that's mine too and so what
for I says report to training command
well they set up that Recon school we
were in the first class right say this
this a clarifi this is the first class
at Fort Brag to train greenber who are
going to be assigned to SOG right so the
first question I got to ask when you get
there are any of the instructors have
ever been in SOG that's a that's a crazy
portion but I get I get there they were
out at Camp Mall which was a training
center at the time they old right glider
which is still there now yeah now for
Robin sage the Final Phase of green bra
they do a lot of training out they
always have that's where the uh the
glider Unit were trained for World War
World II yes sir they still had when I
was in the 82nd there's still gliders
and trees out there in trees yeah they
had never
removed you know they're nothing but
canvas and yeah there were all the
pilots are guys that couldn't make it
through flight schools so they made them
made glil glider Pilots so anyhow I I go
out there and report in the com in the
sarden major tachman was Bill Craig who
was a was a team sord at long oh yeah of
course and of course I knew Bill and he
he says I walk in there and he says what
the [__] are you doing here and I says
it's the only way I could get my get
home was to come here you know so Butch
Butch he sent his family back to the
states he got orders and stuff sent and
he went straight to Vietnam no kidding
yeah he never
went and because he owned a house in
faville so you know his wife could
transition I had to go back and find a
place for Carol in Washington state and
all that stuff so anyhow I get there and
and I told you about the classes I get
there
and like I said all the goddamn on on
platform inst structures were guys out
101st and 173rd and stuff there was no
SF going do not one person there had
served Mac bie sock and I could see why
because it was a typical CL uh can stuff
know right out of an FM that field
manual yeah that this is the way this
class is going to be taught and it was
that same crap you're going to get a
target foldo with all this information
and then you're going to go out and make
a sand table and then
you're sorry that's right this thing is
so finicky
man there we go temperament must be the
female we we're back anyhow they they
and you know we find an objective it
looks like your objective and practice
on it and and we all know how that
worked you know they throw a Target
footage at you and sit there's a
helicopter get on it and then they
started talking about
trackers how to evade trackers and my
God God was it was it any of it related
to what it was really like you've been
there no it was all some I I don't know
who wrote the POI up for this damn thing
but he definitely was not a Recon guy he
didn't what maybe they didn't want to
hat do that they had a manual printed
out tell you the truth the guy had
showed how to put a stable rig was was
uh squirrel sprous he had done all the
photos with cuz I had to send him one of
those manuals back he wanted CU he had
his picture in it and stuff right but it
was it was all this it was like any the
military does it's the best scenario
stuff yeah without being what it's like
being on the ground yeah they didn't
prepare the only thing it prepared these
guys for was this is really dangerous
yeah yeah and and thank God it was at
the end of the war yeah you know see
when I and they the NVA was really
cranking up though
what happened well not only that they'
moved know all the all the mechan all
the units had left right when I got over
there the fifth group was gone their
colors and stuff they you know train
they they you know that headquarters and
I head uh certain major childr is in
there he got killed later on and he he
had a Swedish K was on a wall dropped in
was blowback weapon
around
yeah yeah good guy too he's the one had
escorted Barry Sandler Barry Sadler
around to all his crap to keep him
straight cuz Barry was drunk all the
time he drank a little a little but
let's keep moving now so you you finally
get back to your third tour Duty well I
get I get back there right right I I I
never went to any I went to their field
problem out there instead of at the base
camp drinking coffee got my
depla so any I get back to n and I get
to the fifth group and there's a bunch
of Bob cherry and a bunch of guys who
are SOG guys yeah and that's the only
thing that's open the only thing running
operations is SOG and every all the fobs
are
TFS task forces right and the parades
are gone we we're in B black baseball
caps right you know with your Jump Wings
on it so they're doing that Halo
crap yeah and I'm you know yeah and
you're Halo qualified not HALO jump
Master oh is that that's right so anyhow
Billy Wall's running that deal good deal
Billy wall yeah so I asked children I
get of course he you know I was Oldtimer
by that time yeah all these kind we all
know each you know there's a lot of
incests and Special Forces as you know
and uh he says uh where do you want to
go I says it's far far away for you know
who is possible and he says yeah I see
you I know you're Halo and I says yeah I
says said these people can't can't
understand this is a means of VRA and
we're not successful at Fort Brag how we
going to do the jungles of Vietnam I and
JD bath is a friend of mine with of
course by that time JD had been in oh
yeah well he already ran a mission I ran
into JD he was up there he gave you the
Insight JD I says did they give you a
sobriety test let me see the let me see
the lobotomy scar on your he says he
says you know it's hard to say no and I
says well I'm going to solve that I'm
going to go to as I went to CCS B to it
B me to it so I got to Bam me to it and
it's
a I'm not kidding you it was like guys
running around trying to get a
CIB really well yeah the war was over
sure this is 71 well Elden got the DSC
while I was there I fob4 was still
running operation CCN and CC and CC was
too but the teams at b m til when I got
there were all were all run by uh Luke
lck and vietamese Special Forces that's
part of the Vietnamization process
turning over to and we were the ground
for that wow and I had the only I was a
bright light team the 20th SOS with our
gunships the Air Force yeah and they
wouldn't the green hornets yeah the
green hornets they wouldn't fly without
an American Bright Light Team lead team
oh is that right yeah yeah they told
them sure you know we want it and those
are one of the outstanding units that
was attached to SG for the entire sequ
oh these guys are [__] for hot
absolutely and they had the state of
yard Hues they had November models two
engines yeah and they had Min guns on
the doors they saved our bacon in
November of 68 yeah that's right you
were down
yeah yeah well they saved a lot of and
it was crazy when I got there they put
me down the Recon company as their
operation Sergeant First Sergeant right
a Recon company cuz I had the most
experience well by now were you still an
E7 or had been promoted to still an E7
yeah I was an E7 and
uh they Bob Cherry come up with me and
he they made him in charge of the club
he got rich and I got shot
at and Butch was there yeah he was like
me he want to be he was Halo qualified B
boy so he was there and he was the
operation Sergeant for the Hatcher
forces and
uh so it was it was crazy uh like I
said all this shit's happening the NBA
are coming across the border with tanks
and stuff and the fifth Mech was up at
the DMZ right and that after the uh they
did that big Insurgent on Highway 9 into
into out of CAS
Sante not Sante uh Lamson operation
Lamson 719 7 719 that was going on and
there was they lost dozens of
helicopters what they did was they put
seven seven battalions of Arvin in there
and the only good ones they had they had
a marine unit that was good and they had
an Airborne unit that was good but they
went right up Highway
nine and they sucked them in
they let him come in and they surrounded
them and then they the officers uh ran
on them got in helicopters and left
these it was a turkey shoot and they had
they vietamese helicopters were all shot
up and so they brought this The Jokers
it was a Aviation American Aviation and
those guys went in and pulled everybody
out they lost all kinds of helicopters
dozens yeah and those guys they were
there some new book out are they oh yeah
there was a big story bual was at the
Quant Tre when I was over in the third
tour and he was right down in the middle
of it they were you know they were cut
off and the only thing holding that
upper cor there was a Arvin R Arvin
Ranger and an Arvin Marine unit and
their visors were all real Marines and
and and paratroopers and they fought and
you know they were doing but it was
overwhelming uh they came across they
had t-54 tanks they had all the crap and
they were knocking them out that's when
the toll first come in right and they
had them mounted on Hues and they were
shooting them shooting tanks blowing up
tanks and stuff but so you're down CCS
yeah and they're moving in on us right
so what was that like so did you did you
you went out to a couple missions yeah I
went out on uh uh one of them was
recover body recovery of really Cav
helicopter got shot down on the border
so that was just a strap hanger team or
did that no no it was my team I had a
team Hammer Hammer yeah no kidding yeah
it was my I had the bright light team I
took the best they were all R day
Mountain yards right really good big
guys sure unlike the little Brew I had
and stuff I mean these guy and they were
all they' run missions for years I had
two guys that ran with the madg really
yeah yeah they were good and I went and
recruited these guys cuz I was there I
knew who was really good and they let me
do everything the colonel was in charge
of compound it was like Recon jurs you
know so I sure tell you the truth I when
we close the place up I give F rule all
of our weapons and stuff they they came
Inu and ass you know R Mountain yard
Society oh is that right yeah right yeah
yeah yeah I give them all the weapons
sure give them the keys to this funny
the last mission run out of CCS Iran and
the last mission run out of the B B3
Iran wow so what was the last mission
like well the LA last mission was
another guy a a uh SOS helicopter right
went down in Cambodia o he lost power
and went down and they had all that crap
on it and they didn't want the NBA
getting all the stuff they had they got
everybody out so they sent me in to
destroy the helicopter you know
retrieved a uh dat had a k k ky38 you
know we had sure ky38 that in the
helicopter and it was like n these they
can't figure this [__] out but they want
me you know thermic grenade down stuff
and do all that stuff so I took the
bright light team in there and I got in
there and here we go again you get that
when you're not under Fire constantly
and not you get this lazy attitude you
know sure and we're kind of walking
around like and we're right in this
goddamn open area with elephant grass
and bamboo thickets which is notorious
for that a that AO up there in Cambodia
and uh tell you the truth I wasn't that
far for Mad Dog entered up Mia on that
deal right April 69 yeah April 69 and I
went through training group with Jerry
so and so anyhow work there and next
thing I know we start taking sniper fire
sniper fire yeah and and it got so luck
we get pinned down there and we don't
know where it's coming from because
there was a wood line all around it
we're just just hitting a helicopter
they he arounds hitting a helicopter so
I asked for guns for so they walk they R
the area with the guns and stuff so I
said well well let's let's burn this
baby and get the [__] out of here so put
the thermite grenades in there and and
then all the [__] they had into the
rockets and stuff start going
I never that that didn't reach my
capacity of thinking you know and I was
like oh God and and we looked up and
there was five guys come running across
the field trying the rockets off the
thing had went into their their area
that these NBA were in yeah and they
were trying to they were trying to get
out of there they trying to e and e from
this were all shooting at these guys I
don't think we hit one of them we just
pouring rounds out there wow that was my
last mission it it did it was really
crazy uh we had a laun site uh those a
camp launch sites used to have up there
like they did in all the places and the
one L it was right on the border and we
were closing it down so we sent this
Captain uh and a a driver and a a
Quarter Master kid was the s for
sergeant yeah up there to retrieve all
this stuff and they just drove down the
road like it was well they said they
were under Fire so I got the bright
light team and loaded them on and we
went down there unloaded about a quarter
mile from where they were at and I was
going to land there no no of course and
walk in so we get down there they in the
ditch and a a drain each ditch with
water in it because the rice patties out
there and I drag them out that ditches
and [__] and get them on have we're not
taking any fire or nothing so I sent two
people out to check the area and
everything and I got us you know I had
him us in a a secure position around the
I went over to the Jeep and had all
kinds of holes in it I started looking
at the
holes 5.56 holes that's
7 yeah you can tell the difference so
I'm looking at them and this Captain
seems to be looking at he of course he
know my background you know yeah and I
said so you came on fire there Captain D
we yeah yeah you came under Fire yeah go
he was trying to get a CIB and stuff
because he didn't have one right they
shot they shot the Jeep
up so I Colonel Haro was a
commander he was a classmate of Lindsay
oh is that right yeah col Fred Lindsay
yeah at West Point yeah no kidding yeah
and hardgrave was on there and Fred
Lindsay was a CEO of CCS earlier yeah
for a long time he was different and and
he he got he went down in this on the
air America playing with the oh God the
CIA guy that uh wrote the book at the
Frank SN no um I'll don't think of his
name van Vance oh John Paul Van yeah he
went down there they were going in the
conton and I was I was going to go with
him I was going to take over Recon
company at C at CNC right and they give
me a choice go home and do that and I
said I'm going home yeah we lost this
[__] War man I'm out of here wow and
anyhow I get back there and of course
they bring me in and all this stuff and
I says I told uh the colonel I I want to
talk to you and Bud Spicer was the uh
was the sword major and he was CCN guy
you know bud
was I says this is a setup these guys
shot up this Jeep and
he be quiet about you this guy's an
officer you know and I
says and hard graes it and looks at me
he said what do you think we got to do
and I said get him the [__] out of
here cuz I I'm going to have diarrhea of
the mouth here pretty soon I can't keep
this in they cing a goddamn CIB on these
[__] so the next day they chucked
them out wow that's how sad it was here
at the then we left all the Arvin units
in the area left and we were out there
by ourselves again is that right and
they're bringing t-54 tanks in on B me
to it yeah we it was like it was crazy
time then here we go we left all the
little people of course they were all
yards and they all joined the
furo and stuff B in the Vietnamese we
had in the compound say who explain what
the furo was oh it was a mountain yard
Society basically they wanted their
independence right from the Vietnamese
because they've been persecuted by both
nor Viet and South and South yeah yeah
so they they raced up in
1964 I think or five and basically they
use special forces Ace camps as their
thing and they kidnapped all the SF guys
kept them out of the way and they bared
and you know yeah for the stuff and of
course the VM solution was to come in
and kill them all and there was always
that deal with fur R and and the colonel
in charge of the uh rod in the camp he
was head of furo for that district oh
was that right yeah I knew all of course
they knew you know I was one of them you
know so they I had the only team and
everything else he' come in and smoke
cigarettes and drink coffee me all the
time po so when I left I had all I had
all the rifle racks and stuff and hell I
had everything in cuz you know going to
wind up fighting well it was crazy all
the stuff we had in there were like St
guns with silencers those St guns with
Sil and uh car 98s German rifles they
used in World War II car carbin tons of
carbin
m1s and because they used them for CG
when they used to just the old a camp
deals and I had racks full of these
things then I had a bunch of M16s and
stuff like that no cars okay so you wrap
up you return back to uh um bam I mean
uh okanawa no no no where' you go back
Washington State yeah I went back to
devans oh yeah I went back to devons
that's worse than being a n no I it was
it it was better than brag yeah was that
right yeah it was better than brag and
the big thing was particularly CU
they're doing I had I was a I had a team
I was a team sergeant of the sadum team
and what's his
what special weapons indeed nuclear
included yeah we can't talk about that
it's still classified yeah so I had the
sadum team and Tommy shook had the scuba
team Ron Brockman had the Halo team and
all of us guys in Charlie Company second
P we were all at so guys it was so it
was known is a saga my team won the
Larry thorny award two years in a row
kiding yeah for excellence and training
wow and uh and because I had oh I had
veterans man for hot guys man these guys
you know we went to a reforger in
Germany man hell we almost captured the
whole first
Cal we were on the we on the Ryan River
Cor in air strikes and everything else
is that right yeah oh no simil later
yeah sure of course the town flers had
bullet holes from World War II in all
the buildings yeah it was a big b they
come across the bridge there you know
they getting across the line was a big
deal absolutely and the Germans that
left all their bullet holes there as a
reminder indeed I'll never forget they
had a guest house down there we went
down there later and and my team leader
Captain haard who was a reti colonel
German right he was he was a medic in
Mike force with uh with when sinir was
there he was a uh Buck Sergeant okay he
went to University of Puerto Rico got RC
went to GI Bill and came back on active
duty so he was a Germany I have four
Germans be my AO was Port Port uh Poland
okay because the really yeah Aron
curtain was still up sure yeah so that
was a I had no polish speakers on the
team you know I'd been to Vietnamese
language school you know should have not
we lost that word a going do you so I
had I have German speakers on team and
Pete hanberg who's my medic who was a uh
he'd went he he' went to a school in
Germany and his best friend was one of
the kindergar the kids that the the
super race kids oh right yeah that they
raced sure and and and B and batos was
the SS you know training school said
that was a basis for the 10th Special
Forces group old the desk that that uh
that the commander had there was
Patton's desk oh is that right yeah
that's where Patton run his you know his
uh where he took all the goddam cople
people and put them in charge because
they're the only ones to do out to run
[Laughter]
anything so oh my God anyhow and and and
the headquarter the best building was uh
himmler's home okay yeah so your career
in the arm Army wraps up when I have
come on RC the university
you I had orders to go I got here I got
orderers here being Utah yeah I was Salt
Lake City area yeah we we're skewed me
and Carol and kids all ski I've skied in
Japan Germany all all over the place and
you know it's the bug you catch when
you're young before the lift prices went
up yeah and uh I told you the story
about Billy you know I was supposed to
go to Cornell University right in Etha
New York yeah I went up there for and
the goddamn PMS was a bird colonel
airborne and he saw me and go God sorry
get I'm glad to see these damn officers
were the crap I
got he was so I was going and that
that's really a nice area and Cornell is
an Ivy League school oh sure so Billy
Billy calls me up on the phone bill
we're talking about Billy Alexander who
handles SF assignments at the Pentagon
who you and I had visited different
times get orders direct she handled the
elist in yeah of of the and her husband
is a CIA analyst oh is that right yeah
so you know they they got more analysts
and they got field operators so anyhow
she calls me up and she said Pat I got
bad
news uh you Carol's all excited getting
away from this [__] you know go to Salt
Lake and uh I mean to
IA and she says I got a guy coming back
from from the T group I didn't know him
and he's going to Ren Tech in New York
yeah and they close the oral TC
Detachment up Jesus I got no place to
put him and his home he's from Long
Island and he wants to reti after I what
you know the old saying sympathy is
somewhere between [__] and CIS and the
dictionary you know right you know say
yeah sounds terrible there
Billy new can't wait to get to
Etha and she said I got she says no I
want you think about this she saids you
can still go she I'm not telling you you
can't but I got seven slots open in the
west and I know you guys are
westerners and she told me one of them
was the briam young I said oh boy I'll
fit in
there this one this you know former
Roman Catholic show up there man they
think the sky was falling in
so you I wanted to go to Washington cuz
Carol's from Washington and they had
they had one open it was Washington
State it's over in pulman which is you
know it's like the [__] hole of cord
Lane Idaho it's you know nothing over
there that's too far away yeah it's no
skiing over there too yeah so she said
what University of Utah and I to sign me
up man said so you come out you do to
the RTC program yeah I was the senior
instructor I taught tactics Survivor I
had the youth Scouts was the ranger I
had two Ranger slots and I had four
Airborne slots I could give every year
at what point do you go to the VA as an
employee well what happened was when I
retired I went to work after how many
years Pat 24 seven in Marines and 17 in
the army they even counted my Marine
Court time they
did they better so I I uh I retired and
I I had I went on a recruiting thing you
know filling slots yeah and and football
program always looking for easy jobs for
their
jocks these guy these guys make good
privates in the Airborne you know yeah
yeah and uh so we got them in
introductory into RC classes which was a
credit no credit class and I got them we
were on a body count thing because it
was after Vietnam and you know the
military f a lot of Grace and we just it
was all body count so I I went over
got to know one of the assistant
football coaches and his dad was a
marine at Camp Pon it was a retired
Colonel and Tom Gad and uh he was the
defensive coordinator So I says this
deal he said well that sound like a good
deal go see their academic advisor so I
started getting football players over
now got two of them stayed and got
commissioned after they dropped down
program one of them a colonel so I had
this all this stuff well the guy was the
equipment manager and Facilities guy I
had a stroke putting up a football
players there were some privates in the
Marine
Corp and so they and I was getting ready
to get out and I was going I was
finishing up College you know taking all
his CLP test and all this [__] yeah so
you're you're improving your academic
standing in life as as and you're still
in RC yeah lovely downtown had nothing
to do with academics it was get my
ticket punch for I could get a good job
at a phony degree and you
know I if if the University of Phoenix
was gone then I would have been down
there anyhow they C they called me up
and said they had this would I be
interested in this job yeah and I said
yeah you know working with this all that
stuff so
I I went I went over to a what what four
years I worked for the athletic
department but we were that was before
they packed 12 Football height right
know we were in the Mountain West in the
whack sure and those days and uh you
know our football players you know they
were living five in a house living off
subsist well we put some kids in the NFL
too you know sure oh yeah that that kind
of stuff and and bad thing was BYU was
beating us every year and that was
making stuff happen and uh I got Carol
work for Aeros space Company Hercules
Corporation in Rocket Motors mhm she was
the administrative assistant for the
president of the company wow so a job
open in the over there in is in
documentation as a procedure writer that
you would have fit him perfect your
background you know my my literary thing
consisted of comic books and so I would
have did that and they went the when the
Berlin Wall went down yeah they qu
making all these missiles and stuff so
they sold out to outfit and I got
rifted so I'm out looking for a job you
know that kind of stuff so I said why I
I've tried I post office I was that
desperate yeah so I went down to to
postal test and I passed all of them you
know they give you 10% was that right on
your on your uh if you have purple heart
sure on the test on all my tests were
over 100 with the 10% on so anyhow I was
going oh God I going to I'm not going to
tell anybody I'm a mailman you know yeah
yeah so any I was doing that so I
says let me go over and see what the VA
has off so I go and put him for a job
the VA and they had a job open in in uh
neology which is dialysis and all St for
the administrator to run their right
their they had a home dialysis program
for supplies yeah yeah and all this
stuff and keep all the paperwork stuff
so I went over and interviewed and the
doctor was a German Doctor Who was r
that say and I think he was a little
lary of me because I I was old
more wiser and everything but with the
[__] I had in the military couldn't turn
me down I had a degree yeah he couldn't
turn me down so they harded me and I did
that for two years and the guy who was a
safety engineer for the facility he was
a he was a cannon Cocker in Vietnam uh
he was on Camp Carol really 175 sir yeah
up in iore iore and we got to be friends
va's full of
employees at that time were veterans
sure because you got priorities and so I
got to be friends with him and uh he put
in for another job in in uh uh Denver
where our headquarters was at and he
recommended me for his job well I never
had a background in that you know sure
but as always flexible always so you
know you know next thing you know I'm
[__] Mr o OSHA expert and all this
stuff got on line and and and I had far
protection too so they turned around
they harded me temporary on a temporary
basis right uh 90-day
evaluation so I made it through that and
I worked for a woman she was a head
nurse MH it felt she was my and she was
she loved me because I you know I had a
I had this ability to interface with
people sure and get stuff done so they
decided they're going to send me to fire
protection school at University of
Maryland to learn the engineering about
sprinkler system sure and because I had
to inspect that's a whole science in
itself yeah I had to inspect nursing
homes and all these outpatient clinics
and I had five states I had to do five
five states and uh all these you know
where there's more sheep and people
States Wy
I Nevada but was fun driving through it
yeah what it was I I loved it cuz I was
my own boss I did what I wanted to and
then I had a guy that worked with me he
was the uh in charge of all the uh
industrial stuff like the the liquids
and anything it was car
genuent you know medicines and stuff
like that he had storage of that and
handling of that and he was also what
they called the uh uh emergency
preparedness cuzz that one of our jobs
if they had a you know a biological
chemical attack sure the VA hospitals
turned into a triage Center for all this
stuff oh no kidding yeah and that was
really interesting I got in they sent me
to us they sent me to University of
Colorado a course on that crap and that
was we set up uh tents outside know to
do scrubbing scrub people down and then
the Olympics come in and they 1980 no
when was no no the O Olympics come in in
200000 yeah we had it here in Sol
Governor M and they brought they brought
Romney in the running because of Mormon
church right they wanted and Romney you
know he's an organizer and stuff sure so
he found out I was doing this for the VA
and stuff and they we were in that panic
because of 911 sure and all that crap so
they got me he wanted to put me in
charge of all night I said well they
won't pay me enough money for that do
they he says well he said well maybe we
can come up some out the budget I said I
can't accept that I'm a government
employee can you I said you ought to
know that he was governor sure in
Massachusetts at that and so and he got
he kind of Twisted WR but he got things
done because the guy he had him before
that he had to get a go down to the
temple to have anybody tell him what to
do
but that was interesting they brought
sure my hop pad was used by Bush where
you come in for the yeah thing I had
stand out there with a far extinguisher
as he come out he ran over and shook my
hand he I'm glad to have you farming
here oh okay yeah but uh yeah then I
worked for the VA I retired from there
worked there 11 years reti is
gs12 I'm triple dipping indeed indeed
the hard way the hard way oh my God yeah
so I think we're kind of wrapping up
here any final little thoughts or a
couple little vignettes that you want to
flash back on before we uh begin to draw
the curtain cloth uh when in a far I
find a smallest guy to throw in front of
you words of
wisdom that's that's the reason that's
the reason lud the set of man Blended in
with the mountain yard so easily indeed
I look like an name and steak out there
with these
guys yeah lud deetta who by the way uh
survived the tour Duty with the uh 173rd
it was on 875 875 on Thanksgiving Day or
right before Thanksgiving day he still W
eat Thanksgiving dinner over right when
they took they took the hill and then a
unit we won't say which pilot dropped
the 500 lb bomb on the command post and
that night I mean that's one of those
most weird stories killed all the staff
officer and Lou was there and that night
he was hyper alert because he had so
much activity in the jungle and they
thought he thought that the NVA were
coming but they never attacked because
in the morning when the sunlight came up
he saw that there were animals coming
out to retrieve the body parts that were
in the jungle yeah from that bomb
explosion yeah and Luda said it then
after after a tour Duty with the herd
surviving Hill
875 volunteers to go to SG no that's not
the story there was he went on RNR to n
Trang right and they had the ice cream
machine there and all that of course he
was a a jungle rat you know yeah eating
that
Seas you know L it luging all the water
they used and everything and he says man
this is a life for me I don't want to go
back to the
82nd so he volunteered for Special
Forces and he thought he was going to be
they told him well we'll get you job
here in the train next thing he got
orders said drawer 22 yeah which is the
CNC SOG SOG he ends up with Quan with me
that was his oh yeah he he I'll never
forget he's he came in he was smoking a
cigarette drinking a cup of coffee was L
me a God would neither one smoked or
drank yeah we a little coffee we had all
that se rashing coffee he thought he was
in heaven you know and he sat there and
he said you know what Ser Watkins and I
said no Lou what he said nobody in
wilington Delaware gives a [__] about L
this and I remind him of that all the
time so he's still living in Bear
Delaware hope to get him he called me up
yesterday Diddy how's he doing he's a
hard dude man they had they were
shoveling dirt in his face two times he
said I ain't ready to go yeah yeah he's
still out rting his damn motorcycle he
is he's out there with his daughter and
his granddaughter now beautiful little
girl yeah yeah and but you got to share
with us and before we close out
here how did
Lou capture or eliminate rats at quesa
oh
God we had these silencer pistols high
standards the 22 high standard with a
silencer with a you know which were
front left over from World War II the OS
had that's exactly good for shooting
rats and and and bumblebees that's about
it I be I mean could you see the
Freshman killed a dog with one good my
favorite dog story yeah well anyhow we
had I had I had M mine I got from when I
was there for before and I I used to Lug
it around the pink with it and stuff
like that yeah and Lou fell you know
Lou's knives and guns you know oh God he
this day he come in he had a shoulder
holer you know with a with a brownie
high power in it and all this [__] I was
God God God John Wayne Liv with me so he
he says sard Watkins can I can I uh can
I see your pistol and I said yeah yeah
yeah sh I was up in you know we were in
the bunkers sure oh yeah had mosquit and
N keep the rats off of us cuz they were
just you know they were everywhere oh
yeah feeding these are case rats which
are bigger than cats they they they were
feeding off the NBA there were dead out
there we had sure bodies laying out in
the wire and stuff still from the origin
you know for the big stage and skeletons
all over the place it l a horror movie
and uh anyhow he was taking that sea
rash and cheese and baiting these rats
right this was the nighttime I'm up
there reading something a letter or
something on top and and I hadn't pulled
that net
down and all of a sudden I hear this you
know damn rat war was running across the
upper on upper scale you know and these
rats look like dogs oh yeah big and uh
jungle rats and they he fell down he
wounded and blood's everywhere it's on
my
chest trying to get
away I'm trying to get the rat off me
and all this stuff finally the rat gets
takes off and I turn around and lose
Stander with the pistol and he sees me
you know the arish me had come up indeed
indeed
like yeah I put up with a lot of [__]
but I ain't putting up with you shooting
rats and some so I said give me that
goddamn gun Sergeant I says you you I
will not see you ever again discharge a
weapon without my permission and lose
you know he he was all grunt military a
staff sergeant tells him something man
he did it he listened yeah and he was
like he and all he could say I'm sorry
I'm sorry I said well not only that
you're a piss for shot you only wounded
the damn thing now he's crawled up and
he's going to die up there and stink and
stink a place and maggots are going to
be dropping out and he's and you how Lou
is oh I'll get up there tomorrow some
yards and clean that place out so
they're out there
I I never told him to do it they're
removing sandbags and stuff he's got
that my yard team out there yeah and
they're finding baby rats you know these
little pink rats and they find Nest to
them so the yards are out there they
start a fire and they throwing the baby
rats in there and they're taking about
and eating them like like popcorn you
know and loose I says God damn theetta
you get over there and get your share
you you're the Hun gather at this bunch
it's a whole new definition of rat tat
yeah don't
lie yeah it yeah we had a kid in the you
know we always pra we had so much shrap
no the crap coming in rounds tell you
the truth that I got that picture of
that cober landed up by us that they
couldn't lost the engine power right an
hour later it was on fire they started
shooting at it they mored and everything
sure yeah and it was like don't have any
short rounds get that damn helicopter
you
know so anyhow they picked up there was
one of those haml cans yeah one of the
Yards went up there pick and there was a
seven stepper in there and bit him and
the kid knew what it was of course sure
you know he started running there trying
to tackle him to get him down to going
cut his finger off and he started
foaming at the mouth and died right
there right there he got more than seven
steps with the seven step yeah yeah he
did a
circle of course he had a small body
well look uh we're at that point sir any
any last serious final
thought no it's a pleasure to see that
we have these Young Americans and stuff
and still know how to produce and get
things done absolutely we're here at uh
um again with Michael Glover's Center
one of his three offices his
headquarters for uh fieldcraft survival
and uh we've had just a couple events
here the weekend where there's seals
combat seals DJ and Cole who've been
through over 10 years of combat both
they've been together 16 years medically
discharged medically discharged but you
look at they're still in shape and
they're all they're starting their
podcast soon well I I challenge them if
they could run as fast as we could to a
helicopter Under Fire under like they
were too but the oh it's just amazing
and each new generation ation that
continues to build and there are still
Americans out there that stepping up to
the plate to serve our country oh you
got a stepson who was in in Afghanistan
he got blown up no he's in Iraq but he
was he was blown up he's back in track
now and he's uh he's in construction but
thank you for mentioning Evan yeah EV
our pride and joy yeah a good kid
absolutely well with that sir we're
going to close out thank you for being
with us and we as always when we in
closing we thank our military border
patrol First
Responders and the and today because of
our historic moment in time with the
Ukraine erupting with the Russian
invasion uh we're not sure what's going
to stem from all that but for our
military particular we thank them we
also thank the men and women who have
served in years past her was like Pat
Watkins a man that I've admired who
helped me and many a young Green Beret
we land at fub1 shared his expertise
along with John McGovern and of course
spider parks and U I like to think
that's part of the reason why I survived
was thanks to getting the handoff and
you gentlemen just worried about the
rifle range with you guys indeed well we
won't talk about that now we also
remember and salute the men and women
who have not been able to return and
today we still have
1,583 Americans that are still
officially listed as missing an action
in Southeast Asia from the Vietnam world
that includes Vietnam Cambodia and and
Laos North Vietnam and North Vietnam
that's Vietnam is one country now and
then uh there's a couple that from China
and a couple in Thailand we we but we uh
but we salute them and those have served
our country today and we also want to
thank again Joo willing Productions his
team with Eko Charles and our newest
member swinging hot and heavy here
helping us out good old Carrie hton and
we thank um and we're doing it in
conjunction with SG Chronicles and uh if
you haven't seen SOG podcast number 23
that's another one with sergeant major
Pat Watkins here so again thank you for
joining us hope you enjoyed the show God
Bless
America